- Vangelis créait des paysages
sonores re. Son inre. Son inre.e
mélodie dans le film
"Les Chariots de feu" lui a valu
en 1981 le Oscar de la meilleure
musique.
eur de musique de films
- Sa musique, elle vivait par
elle-même. Tu enlèves le film
et c'est encore bon.
Pour moi, c'est une grande
♪ ♪ ♪
- Avec le film "Blade Runner", r
grec a encore fait sa marque.
Dix ans
aussi la musique du film
Christophe Colomb",
également du réalisateur
- Il a marqué quand même la
film en utilisant l'éctronique,
mais bien. Le côté mélodique
était beau, ses couleurseurs
vraiment, vraiment intéressantes
et c'est un classique.
- Oui, c'est vrai. La plupart
du temps, je joue seul. Oui,
- Pionnier de la musique
électronique, Vangelis a amorcé
sa carrière au milieu des années
remarqué par le groupe
progressif Yes. Avec le chanteur
Jon Anderson, il réalisera
Jon & Vangelis.
- Moi, je ne fais que, comme
je vous dis, servir la musique,
rien d'autre.♪ ♪ ♪
- Musicien infatig
Vangelis a composé jusqu'à
la fin de sa vie.
disques étaient inspirés
par l'exspatiale.
- C'est une grande perte.
C'est tr
musicien comme ça, de cette
qualité-quitte.
- Vangelis nous quitte
à l'âge de 79 ans. Selon des
médias grecs, il serait décédée.
Il nous laisse une oeuvre
puissante. Musicalement,
il s'est rendu là où aucun autre
- Peut-être, peut-être le rêve,
c'est la vraie réa
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-